foreign
[Music]
that's bad really glad to be with you
here today um we have a lot to get to
and look I want to be clear about
something it's not lost on me that there
are going to be factions no matter how
we address some of these stories we're
not talking about the Elon Musk Apple
thing we're all on board with that uh
but obviously what happened yesterday
with Kanye Tim pool
um Milo and Nick Fuentes uh and I want
to be clear about something you probably
have noticed I'm not in the business of
really attacking other conservatives
even if I disagree with them
the point at which that changes and I
would love to hear from you before we
get into this
um for me because I think we all have a
litmus test not a purity test but we all
do have a yardstick is at a certain
point when people who maybe claim to be
conservatives are seeking to do
nothing more than damage
particularly damage to the truth
and if there's one thing that I I really
we really do are damnedest to try and
see here at the show it's the truth
that's why we make all the references
available and before I get into what's
happening here kind of on the right and
some people who are disagreeing and
hopefully we'll cover it in a balanced
way I I realized actually just driving
in the car the other day almost all my
ideas come to me when I'm in the car I
don't know if you do you have this
listening to music usually it's like
maybe it's sensory deprivation I need to
get one of those salt water tanks can we
get Joe Rogan on the phone
but I realize that my real problem with
the left today the progressive left and
I think a lot of you maybe have this
problem but we haven't been able to put
a finer point on it we can argue all we
want about how many genders there are
and the sort of the culture War
but it's a symptom of something pretty
um pervasive pernicious all the peace uh
that the left today is is quite
literally and I'm using the term
literally not figuratively trying to
reverse reality itself
it's almost in it's almost this sort of
inverted parallel universe look let me
give you an example
we know as conservatives uh or as uh
God-fearing uh citizens of this country
uh that biology is innate and the left
even accepts this to a certain degree
male female right that's sex that's
biology gender socially constructed
because they don't believe it by the way
because what is it it's what to what
trans male it's male to female
trans female to male it's not man to
woman it's not woman to man so right
away that kind of goes out the window
but let's let's accept their premise for
a second we know that biology is an
eight and certainly as a Christian I
think that many of you also would agree
even if you're just Christian
sympathizers or theists that values are
instilled
right values are not Universal you're
born male or female you have no choice
over the matter
but values and you hear this a lot you
know when I was on YouTube back in 2009
there were no conservatives there really
were no Christians the common argument
was if I need a Flying Spaghetti Monster
to tell me not to kill then I'm a
horrible person you're just a horrible
person using God as a crutch well hold
on a second
the idea of not killing that's not a
universal value
certainly for a long time calling the
week wasn't considered murder
Mercy is not a universal value Mercy was
actually seen as a weakness up until
modern Christendom let's not just use
murder as an example let's talk about
values like theft
the concept of personal property hey why
don't you cheat on your wife
why don't we have child Brides
oh if I need a God to tell me not to
have a child right I'm a horrible person
well there are plenty of places across
the globe right now still have child
rights
monogamy isn't a thing in a lot of these
countries
theft is not punishable in the same way
that it is here when you go down the
list of values you have to realize
inherently that they are not innate so
we know that biology is innate and
values are instilled the left wants you
to believe the exact opposite they want
you to believe and this is the argument
that they're making that biology is
instilled
that gender and really like we said sex
they're interchangeable now
are
instilled it's not an eight you're not
you're not born male or female but they
want you to believe that values are
innate I don't need a God to tell me to
insert whatever it is here so while we
know that biology is innate and values
are instilled and if you don't accept
that premise you are doomed to a society
that will crumble because you will have
a society that no longer instills values
because you take them for granted
and we have a society right now that
wants us to believe
that biology is instilled by some social
construct but that these values we take
for granted and we take for granted
specifically because of the cumulative
effect of these values being instilled
into the citizens of our nation and the
founders of our nation they want you to
believe that those are inherently innate
and there's no risk of those going away
it's the exact opposite if you do not
stay like a dog on a bone in instilling
values and reiterating them and
strengthening them on a generation by
generation basis you are doomed to fail
so it's not about trans and the gender
bender gay marriage or or even the uh
whatever the company was like Bella
Bella siaga I always forget the name
some company no one cares about with
bondage kids in commercials uh it's not
just about that it's about the idea of
society itself and reality and truth
there's a direct attack on Truth taking
place right now and I think that's why
people are getting so aggravated and
they're not always able to communicate
it we'll be talking about that today
before we get into anything I want you
to know I do not think that Kanye West
is a dumb person there's a difference
between being dumb and being
inarticulate he's an artist he's not a
speaker so please understand that as we
examine this conversation it is through
the lens of seeking truth and uh not to
denigrate any one individual but I do
think that we're at a turning point here
we've been making some great strides
and we just can't give over the
territory that's been hard fought
because it's been a long battle and
right now through the end of the year
all of you it is a battle
of inches that's why you have to fight
like hell and we are closing out our
Rebels with a cause tour which has been
fighting like hell just to not be
removed from venues Baltimore uh
December 3rd see you there let's get on
with the show
[Applause]
this fall prepare
for two
Rebels with a Cause
[Applause]
the rebels with a cause Comedy Tour
tickets on sale now at louder with
crowder.com tour I'm just not ready to
have to take care of another human being
it's not your fault it's the man's it's
not my responsibility a baby is not the
mother's responsibility baby I just want
to make sure that I'm making the right
decision you know because I'm so young
and I've got my whole life ahead of me
and I wasn't trying to do this and it's
stupid
yeah baby it's not your fault that you
let a man in you so I should go back to
being selfish yes be a selfish woman get
rid of your baby
not cute yeah you got an ugly preemie
bearded baby
it doesn't cry I think it has Asperger's
that's going to be even more expensive
special schools
you gotta get rid of it just throw it
into stupid baby River
[Music]
you're right
yeah there you go he doesn't even cry I
think he has Asperger's
[Music]
right now
see Bobby it's having a great time going
down the river he's not even scared
right this was the right choice I know
what was the right choice I wouldn't
steer you wrong
if he sees wrong he's dead
[Music]
away
[Music]
we're up
one man's trash got a new slave
everybody oh got a new slave you ever
catch a slave this big Frank no you
didn't new slave right here oh well oh
wow
let's get out of here
why don't you cry
you have Asperger's
[Music]
.com
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you remember one of those moments where
you just realized something that you do
every day you're going oh my gosh
there's a lot to keep track of here I
got a timer I got I got you guys telling
me when I gotta go I gotta bring up
Clips I have to provide references
that's a lot yeah I'm not a maestro oh
you are kind of yeah yeah all right glad
to be why do you make us call you the
Maestro well that's a separate it's
above your office door that's a
contractual issue more of a power move
really yes well it works Western got a
problem with it you're trying to control
my finances huh okay so this is going to
be one of those shows look just just
please let us provide you with all of
the context that we can before you get
mad or you know some people I know there
will be this reflexive reaction of oh
that person I like this person and I
unders I have to be careful here because
I've had interactions with a lot of
people who are involved with these
stories you know that I know Tim Paul's
a friend
um you know I've had interactions with
Milo yiannopoulos quite a bit I haven't
had any interactions with Nick you know
that I've been a Kanye I know some
people say yay I I don't mean anything
by it it's not like I'm trying to call
you Cassius Clay even though you ditched
your slave name and join the Nation of
Islam it's just I know it was Kanye
because I listened to you growing up I'm
a huge fan of Kanye West
but this is something we're going to
have to address uh based on what
happened yesterday and has come to a
boiling point but more importantly I
want to talk today about the White House
about big Tech and every major media
Outlet right now targeting musk and it's
not because it's not a free speech issue
actually let me clarify it's not only a
free speech issue the consequence right
the ramifications are it could include
the loss of free speech it's about
eliminating competition you have five
companies
well you have two companies who control
95 percent of the information allowed on
the App Store and you have five
companies who control virtually all of
the exchange of information online
trying to eliminate the one person the
one person who's decided that they
aren't going to go along with it with
Elon Musk and you have these dog
whistles from the White House saying
yeah yeah more of that let's eliminate
these people because they are dangerous
and I think Jordan Peterson has talked
about this I've been talking about it
for years your goal should always be
to be a dangerous person
and to not have to wield it people
should fear you people should respect
you and you should be uh gentle and
gracious and then carry a big stick when
you need it so we'll be talking about
all of that and more jail how are you
I'm doing well a little pissed off
really a little bit oh a little fiery
hey
this is this is
better see that's what I have did you
remember those commercials of Burger
King commercials with Joel McHale yeah
um spicy oh yeah it was pretty funny
this is pretty funny there's untoxic I'm
like it's the spicy guys you're like
what the hell are you talking about I'm
like I yeah the Asperger's it's what it
is you just don't cry you're gonna end
up in the stupid baby River yes you are
that's a perfect intro for today's show
I was thinking yeah that's the greatest
voice I could have done and just for
people who don't know why well we're
running all of the lottery Bible stories
I think there's six or seven because we
realize that sometimes you miss them so
you get to see them chronologically all
the way up to the Rapture uh you know
them you love them fastest man on his
feet our last show this year still has
some tickets left Baltimore Maryland
December 3rd go to lottery.com tour for
tickets it's the only place that has had
tickets left for a very long time and
I've heard you people in DC and Virginia
I thought this was close enough and
you're like yeah it might as well be the
middle of nowhere we're not going to
Baltimore
yeah so I hear you sorry lesson learned
fastest man on his feet quickest Whitney
West Dave Lander how are you sir Ahoy
good how about you good yes getting
ready to navigate this Minefield I know
I'm kind of wondering how we're gonna do
this well at least I look like I'm 12. I
shaved for real today and I don't like
it it's more so that you're wearing a
hat that's two sizes it's got Woods in
the owl you look like the Cosby kid with
the thing that's all over his chalk
demon on my shirt too of me and you oh
that's right a fan came up and gave
those to us I don't think that's a good
shirt to wear them out of context I
realized a lot of the things that have
involved me so far today is not good
don't worry I'm about to top it so
before we get to it what are your
thoughts on yay on Kanye West walking up
that's the question of the day we'll
have a lot of questions today and the
Tim pool uh show is it Tim pool podcast
is it Tim casting our IRS IRL is what he
was on yeah okay so we'll be talking
about that quite a bit and I think the
more important story is what's going on
here with apple and with Elon Musk and
big Tech and then also I don't know if
you know this the rail workers strike
which was just pushed it was going to
happen before the election in like OPEC
Biden said can you just push it to after
the election sure you don't need
Dominion voting machines to be rigged
for an election to not be fair if you
just push all the economic Calamity to
after the election hey that's enough of
course also covering up the uh you know
smoking crap and crack and sexting your
niece that also helps they didn't smoke
cheese you would call it crap that's
true either way depends on what kind of
cheese yeah I wouldn't call it that it
was a nice kerrygold no grass-fed from
Ireland yep gouda that's what people
tell me something about vitamin K I
don't know we're gonna try and thread
this needle speaking of threading the
needle here's someone who can't Doug
so this happened this weekend and I sent
it to you I sent it to everybody I
haven't seen it yet oh it's good you
haven't seen it yet brush eyes you
didn't send it to Gerald it's everybody
but me I wasn't going to bring that up
so the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade uh
you know they had the uh the the lgbtq
band which just means it's a lesser band
not because they're gay but because
every member from what Anderson has to
be gay I don't know why this should be
in a Children's Parade but that just
means that you're drawing from two
percent of the talent pool they were
definitively bad and I did notice a
theme of fat Pride at the Macy's Parade
uh
and I was watching this and look there's
nothing wrong with being you know having
a little bit more you know you know it's
a little bit of a weight problem
sometimes may Betty so I get it however
if your job is to be a cheerleader if
your job uh includes uh athletic
endeavors
it would seem to reason that it would
help to be athletic so this is one of
what are they called rangerettes I don't
know baton twirler and before what you
are about to see happened I turned to my
sister-in-law and I said yeah that
broad's going to get winded there's no
way she's making it all the way through
this that's a two and a half come on no
that's not be nice and then this
happened and she just hung her head and
said okay I get it now this is at the
Macy's day parade everyone missed this
see if you can spot the moment where
this woman realizes that she is in uh
over her chins
lower right lower right look at this
throw in the kick
[Laughter]
show it one more time for those who
missed it it's like a Steven Seagal kick
there's plenty of time to do a perfect
roundhouse kick
look baton goes up she completes the
kick and still has three seconds to win
just for comparison can we get like an
actual kick like you've seen people do
this they're very very very athletically
gifted it's her first day yes yeah
the Rockettes in 10 years just throwing
knees somebody out there like well they
kicked Kai there's only six of them on
the whole stage like we'd like to have
more we just can't like if this is just
someone doing kickwork at the gym you
wouldn't say a word right when it's your
job to throw an impressive kick as part
of the grand finale in the parade you
should probably be able to maintain your
wind long enough to throw a kick little
or fake it that's just we can it's like
when you see someone jogging you ever
see someone jogging when you're driving
to the car and they look around and they
start walking I always make a point to
roll down my window and laugh
yes that was someone giving up in plain
views
I said I threw a pennies but you're
gonna Huck cheeseburgers at them I
actually I've had Stephen yell at me
from many times yeah I'm just kidding
it's more of a speed walk yeah yeah by
the way it doesn't require as much Lycra
as you think it does just eating ice
cream that's how we're walking
yeah
hey shouldn't little girls be looking up
you know look at what happened like
little girls want to look up like ah
someone who's a great athlete look it's
not lost I mean incredible athletes
cheerleaders Ranger whatever the people
who do the baton twirling they do the
rifle whatever I don't know the names of
them my point is hats off to you it is
difficult how are you allowing
such non-athletes amongst your ranks I
got it I got one because she doesn't
have a rifle yeah he this guy's probably
the LGBT community but check this out
[Music]
of course it's Freddie Mercury
be asking Simon to call him
Here Comes his kick I hope comes a kick
wow all right
that was a little higher just I mean
that's a lot of effort to get your debt
on to talk to you again
did you see me what who's this yeah I
keep sending it to voicemail why the
sequins if you're not doing anything
useful go in backstage get my stuff ah
good you're stretchy that's great I'm
gonna call your sister yeah I wonder how
you got to be so bendy yeah it's a
mystery to me she goes to college at
Berkeley I guess you're both gifted yes
uh anyway I just thought I was peeing
myself laughing on Thanksgiving then I
watched the dog show so you watch you
watch the dog show yes I did
yes I did what is it the West the
Westminster doctor well John O'Hurley
was on this show sorry I always think
that I always get the two confused that
we've done it before but if you think so
no just the West Baptist dog show yes
God hates toys
I don't well maybe whatever I don't know
they have all kinds they're all white
dogs God hates Chihuahuas well that's
probably be careful talking about white
dogs about to cross them lines okay okay
sorry
hey I love dogs Joe Lewis didn't hear it
okay he's good it's not his fault he was
born that way right now he's loving of
all dogs he doesn't have to be so proud
of it it's true yeah also I don't know
why he has so many hoods so
Kanye West on Tim Poole all right this
just happened last night this is making
the rounds everywhere uh full disclosure
obviously Tim Paul's been on the show
many times uh I consider myself friendly
with Tim Poole I actually think that Tim
pool is you know I think he's being
attacked from both sides I actually
think he did a pretty fair job but look
this is what happened Kanye West yay for
people who are not familiar sure it was
P Diddy is he still did he was Puff
Daddy then he was puffy then he was he
just changed too many times okay Sean
Combs is how I Sean Connery right all
right me and his accountant call him
that right either way someone's getting
shot in a nightclub yes so
uh Kanye West appeared alongside Tim
pool uh with his I guess people who are
working on his campaign or advisors
right this was the dinner that had taken
place at uh Mar-A-Lago I don't really
know if it was a dinner so much as a
brief snack and there are a lot of
questions surrounding it we didn't talk
about it yesterday because we didn't
have the answers I was hoping we would
get some answers here in Tim Poole's
show instead Kanye West abruptly left
walked off the show when the discussion
veered into his views uh on Jewish
people and whether or not it was
anti-semitic here's a clip for those who
missed it they tried to lock me up
that's what it because every time I'm
just holding stride and it's like I
didn't I thought it was more Malcolm X
but I find out I'm more MLK because as
I'm getting hoes down every day by the
press and financially I'm just standing
there and when when I found out that
they tried to put me in jail it was like
a dog was biting my arm and I I I'm I
almost shed a tear almost and I still
walked in stride through it yeah I think
I think they've been extremely unfair to
you who was they though we can't tell
you they is I'm not using the I don't
use the word as the as the way I guess
you guys use I'm talking to them though
isn't it I mean because because when you
think about it consider it
what do I mean like uh uh okay so how
about
already the walk-off
that's a problem
he's gone I'll say it right now ask him
a question
you got I I you guys want to bring that
stuff up
okay
you think yay's gonna come in here and
say Here's my opinions my suffering I'm
gonna say I hear you and then he's gonna
say and it was Jewish people and I'm
gonna be like okay but don't you
consider so I'm not gonna do this make
sure he's cool yeah so look that's a
problem if you're running for office
period especially if you're running for
office on the platform of free speech
and exchange of ideas right if you ask
someone a question and they disagree
with you in a way that I think is pretty
respectful you can't walk off in a huff
that about tells you how capable Kanye
West is at being potentially president
of the United States personally I was in
that chair a week and a half ago and now
Kanye West is he's not mentally well no
I I'm not entirely we shouldn't share a
chair no we shouldn't he's ye I didn't
share it here by the way I just haven't
done Temple because I haven't gone out
to Virginia just yeah you son of a [ __ ]
this is gonna be a whole thing sorry I
loved Tim this is the whole thing the
yay thing and most people out there
going who's yay Kanye what'd you say
Kanye let me set this up real before I
get to him by the way a little Puff
Daddy's name is Love
what he said love is my real name I just
changed my name to love uh it's what's
on my driver's license that's my
official name the ego on these guys like
I realize I'm not like Malcolm X I'm
more like and
like in Christ it's like I'm love
you did proactive commercials okay you
don't get to claim but my name's Agape
oh good you learned a Latin word shut up
yeah in what way are you like Malcolm X
and MLK because there's two things that
happen to them and you're fine yeah well
I will say he's not necessarily fine so
let me let me present my point of view
here Kanye West has been wronged okay
this is absolutely true he has been
wronged we'll get into he was medicated
he was institutionalized he's been
threatened he was wronged and I do think
that he has valid reasons to be upset uh
and I think what people are missing now
people saying oh he should be able to
say sure he should be able to say
whatever he wants and I don't
necessarily know which portions
well I shouldn't say I don't know every
portion I've heard I can tell you which
part is anti-Semitic or which part isn't
uh I don't know all of the comments that
he's made let me put it that way but
Kanye West has been wronged and the
people right now who are supporting him
saying hey he's being silenced for what
he said
sure I understand but he's being wronged
now
he's being wronged by a new set of
people who are taking advantage of him
trying to say look look look look look
how wrong you've been in the past it
just happens to the people who are
wronging him now
they're not Jewish
and I don't by the way just to be clear
I am not someone who is against speaking
in generalizations what I am against is
speaking in unspecified unsubstantiated
unsubstantiated generalizations for
example if I were to say hey 80
something percent of divorces in this
country are initiated by women that's a
generalization I'm giving you a
statistic if I were to say hey as a
voting block American uh Jews tend to
vote pretty liberal which would seem to
go against their self-interest in a lot
of ways considering people who are
practicing Jews and their values that's
that's a statistic you can talk about to
say hey all Jews are ex that's now a
generalization that's unsubstantiated so
just to be clear I'm not someone who
doesn't believe that generalizations
play their their role and that they are
useful sometimes people say it's all
about the individual it's not only
always about the individual that's not
lost on me now Kanye's been wronged he's
being wronged now to begin with some
people are criticizing Tim Poole for
being unfair by pulling up a headline on
the outset of the interview Kanye only
lasted 25 minutes before he walked off
and the headline included the the notion
of anti-Semitism here's a clip uh I'll
just pull up this story from the hill
which is from earlier today 5 PM Pence
says Trump should apologize it's wrong
to give anti-semite a seat at the table
this of course is related to a dinner
that happened and I I was wrong a little
on the details so a dinner happened uh
Nick you were there yay you were there I
just want to start off by how did this
dinner come to happen and and what
happened
foreign
for about a month we had scheduled the
dinner in October that gives you the
context of how Tim Poole set it up he
didn't seem to be uh incapable of
dealing with that question at the time
so it's relevant because what Tim Poole
does his show is they go through news
right they go through news and they ask
their guests to discuss news
we talk about news it's a big reason we
don't really have guests on so much
anymore because often it's just you guys
don't want them to talk about the news
we'll bring a guest on when we want to
discuss the guest they are the new story
in this case I think it's appropriate
Kanye West was a news story uh I mean
people are complaining you can comment
below that Tim Poole might have
interrupted a guess like Tim Pauline I
guess no
that happened sometimes he didn't do it
as much though with Kanye nobody has
ever been interrupted on a podcast never
never does Kanye
I like to have a laugh no but it's true
look so Tim addressed the point that you
made just a second ago at the outset
because Kanye said when we were
backstage you said I would were
backstage in The Green Room whatever you
said that I would be I would do well
with the black vote and Tim clarified
he's like yeah I think you would
resonate kind of within every minute he
goes but you're looking at the black
vote as are they and he goes no what I'm
saying is historically the black vote
has tended to go One Direction and I
think he would do well with that
category I try not to get into
generalizations of they so they had
already talked about this yeah before
and I don't think that's the most
articulate way to put it I don't want to
be in generalizations but I made a
generalization what you need to say is
they're substantiated generalizations
that you need to make for the sake of
Remedy and then there are gross
generalizations that may be wholly
inaccurate and that's where a
conversation needs to be had about your
generalization to examine whether it's
accurate yeah I mean I can definitely
see certain things as a misstep like
that but I think really being in that
situation you have ye in there and he's
got the same issues that you know you do
which is he does and so you pull it on
me I'm going to do it to you did I say
yes
it's easy
yeah he had a baby yes all right yay
yeah so yay
I get it I don't but you know what he's
wrong yeah no but I if you're there and
he's just trying to he's trying to get
he doesn't want to be demonetized he
doesn't want to be de-platformed he
can't just hand a mic to somebody and be
like say whatever you want to because we
do know that right now wherever Kanye's
mental state is he's going to go off on
something that can get Tim de-platformed
I mean there's a lot of working elements
So for anybody to go at him about it
doesn't make any sense to me right I
think and this is I agree with you my
only slight difference of opinion is if
you're worried about deep being the
platformed by hosting that person then
don't host that person for example we've
had Alex Jones on many times immediately
after he was de-platformed it was a risk
we were willing to take sure one time we
got removed for it another time we
didn't
Dems the dice it's high risk High reward
right if you're trying to have a big
name guest especially someone who yeah
courts controversy so let me when I
honestly like honey at you though
honestly and I don't think he hates
Jewish people I really don't no I don't
think he hates Jewish people I think
he's been wronged and I think that he's
aiming sometimes a Howitzer he's being
imprecise right yes um but he's not
wrong about everything look is there a
conversation to be had
about secular humanists with Jewish last
names in Hollywood exploiting people uh
in positions of uh you know the
performance arts Talent yeah yeah and by
the way that happens in the conservative
movement too behind the scenes people
sign contracts where they don't know
what they're signing yeah it's true is
there a disproportional uh
disproportionate number of people with
Jewish last names in higher banking
that's that's an argument that can be
made
but then when you get to it's because
they're Jewish and all well now we have
a problem not because it's offensive but
because it's inaccurate so let me first
set this up Kanye West has been wronged
and I do think that this matters because
it might provide some context as to uh
his mental state so early November he
released some text messages
and all these references are available
at lastcar.com his personal trainer uh
Harley uh posternic I believe is how
it's spelled tried to have him committed
this is what the guy said I'm going to
help you one of a couple ways first you
and I sit down and have a loving and
open conversation but you don't use cuss
words and everything that is discussed
is based in fact and not some crazy
stuff that dumb friend of yours told you
or you saw in a tweet second option I
have you institutionalized again where
they medicate the crap out of you and
you go back to Zombieland forever play
date with kids just won't be the same
okay let me be really clear about
something that's the level of evil that
warrants a face-to-face ass kicking
invoking the guy's children and by the
way a lot of people it's a very common
fear of being locked up of being
institutionalized against you that is
cruelty and keep in mind this is someone
who has been hospitalized allegedly
against his will and that does look
people use the term triggered or PTSD
being locked up against your will and
drugged out of your mind that'll do it
that will do it let's go to 2016 Pastor
nick uh ish he had a there was a phone
call that he made that resulted in Kanye
West being hospitalized and by the way
this is a guy well it's parsh kind of
the conspiracy theories versus reality
Pastor he experimented on Canadian
soldiers on behalf of Canada's
Department of National Defense uh this
is where some people have said MK Ultra
wasn't able to substantiate that that
seems like it's more of a CIA American
program it is real just to be clear yeah
but he did experiment on Canadian
soldiers and this does seem to be a man
who is capable of Cruelty and issued
cruel threats and this is someone who
was probably mentally abusing Kanye West
for a very significant amount of time
here is uh this man talking about the
experiments in an interview so working
for the military I wasn't governed by
the same laws that the typical person
was so I could look at the impact of
certain drugs that are not that are not
interviewing themselves so we looked at
a drug called modafinil which was for
narcoleptics so if you give a soldier
this drug uh how long could they stay
awake for without uh having any health
detriment it's very interesting
modafinil
it will keep you awake it's not a
stimulant it looks like them so if a
special forces person has to stay awake
for three nights waiting for the right
opportunity to do whatever they have to
do we could give them a modafinil and
we'd keep them alert so this is a
douchebag is familiar with pharmacology
who has used it to experiment on
soldiers and is threatening to use it
against Kanye West against his his will
he's also helps people like Mac Miller
uh Ellen Page before she was Elliot he's
really been why don't you Brittany 100.
yeah go ahead and Google who this guy
has helped let me guess Amy Winehouse
yep oh yeah oh really yeah oh that was
just a guess yeah yeah yeah good guess
oh what a piece of [ __ ] no this guy yeah
he's yeah Elliott Smith
Morrison yeah he cleans stuff up that
guy in A Star is Born I don't know his
name yeah uh he's Luca brazi let's be
honest so here's the thing Kanye West
was was wronged he was used here's the
thing he's being used now so there are a
couple different theories as to what's
been going and this is just some of this
is going to be speculation hopefully I
can present a case to you uh as to why
so uh remember this is what happened you
know it was last week there was Kanye
West he brought Nick Fuentes uh uh Nick
Nicholas Fuentes Miley Annapolis to
Mar-A-Lago for a dinner with uh Donald
Trump okay
so that happened by the way hit the like
button hit share because this is
something that is being memory hold on
YouTube and we'll talk about Apple and
Elon Musk it's probably going to be a
little bit longer of a show today just
to let you know uh here's the thing
so Kanye West uh has brought in someone
like like Milo and someone like Nick
Fuentes now the motivations there do
matter if you're a conservative
right let's say you like Donald Trump
let's say you like Ron DeSantis
it doesn't really matter because these
people
I would argue want to destroy all of it
they don't want the conservative
movement they don't want Republicans to
do well they certainly don't want Trump
to do well there is a personal Vendetta
against Donald Trump with these
individuals so he brought these
individuals to Mar-A-Lago which was not
vetted by uh Donald Trump which I think
was foolish yeah I don't think you
should let anyone in there and sit down
with with them for dinner
um if their goal was to was to actually
uh basically inflict damage on Donald
Trump well then it's been incredibly
effective because it's been a media
cycle now for three days and
myelinopolis has quite literally
communicated in the past because he felt
wronged his desire to take Donald Trump
down here you go here's a quote I lost
everything helping put Trump in office
my life and career were completely
destroyed was it worth it no I feel
other utterly betrayed I will have
Vengeance I am dedicating the rest of my
life to the destruction of the
Republican Party burn the Republican
party to the effing ground geez that
seems pretty clear in motivation so my
question is then okay
Kanye West did he know or did he not
know but I think it would be pretty
clear as to Milo yiannopoulos's motives
going going to Mar-A-Lago and goading
Kanye West at this point Kanye West is
being I believe used as a pawn again and
you guys shouldn't be championing it
because he says a couple of things that
you like
the guy needs some help yeah the guy
needs some support not from charlatans
let's go down the list to the certain
Fuentes character he once called Donald
Trump cucked for and he was very upset
that Donald Trump disavowed white
supremacy yeah for him to disavow white
supremacy is very cocked and blue pilled
you know totally totally wrong
okay yeah why would a president do that
yeah why would a president so for the
same reasons that we liked him or we
said it was pretty clear that he said
I'm not I'm not talking about white
supremacists who should be disavowed
totally right so I'm not talking about
them they were fine people on both sides
you do have people out there who
actually hate that Donald Trump
disavowed white supremacy is that you
because if that's not you if you if you
like that Donald Trump disavowed white
supremacy while saying there were fine
people on both sides who supported uh at
least recognizing Our Heritage with
monuments that might have been a part of
the Confederacy and that there were
liberals on the other side who had an
argument to take them down if you like
the fact that Donald Trump actually
I guess actually message to both
portions of the voting constituency
while condemning white supremacy if you
like that well then you can't be in
alignment with these guys yeah well and
their whole intention it seems like you
said was just to be a disrupter to go in
and obviously we've kind of shown you
some of Milo's tweets there or I guess
it was on parlor that he was saying
those things right and he he has obvious
intentions it drove conservatives away
from Donald Trump right because now
they're seeing Kanye go in and say I'm
running for office I'm going to be
president Milo is the campaign manager
essentially for Kanye right now I have
no idea what Fuentes is doing anywhere
near this group of people
but it is damaging the crap out of the
Republican party and out of Donald Trump
just by having him there and you said it
right that's a mistake on his part if he
is going to run an effective campaign to
become president again of the United
States that kind of stuff can't happen
right because it's very very easy for
those groups to just kind of walk up
beside and that's all the media needs
and of course if if yay sorry I almost
did it again silly me it's almost like
all this is stupid if yay Wants to Be an
Effective president he also has to do
better than that and just to be clear
I've you know I've had interactions with
Milo with Tim Poole I haven't had any
interactions with with Nick Fuentes but
here is something that I will say
it's fine to have disagreements you know
Ben Shapiro and I have disagreements I
think that the internet is a better
place the world is a better place for
someone like Ben Shapiro being out there
than not being out there uh Rand Paul
and I and I have disagreements I think
that we are better off having a
representative like him than not same
thing with Ted Cruz right certainly I
would take him over beta so there can be
disagreements when there are people
though in the movement whose only goal
is to destroy with no intent of building
that's where you say okay this is a bad
actor that's where you say the term
grifter that's where you say this is a
charlatan so the only interaction that I
have ever had with Nick Fuentes was we
did a show at Gerald was there at Texas
A M and at this point I guess he was
organizing a group called The groupers
and their whole thing was going after
anyone who they saw is cut you know like
Donald Trump disavowing white supremacy
and so uh we you know have our tentacles
in every group on Facebook we kind of
keep tabs on people and so we know that
they were planning on coming and and
storming the Q a session you know kind
of loading it up
um because I'm an open borders cuck if
you know anything about me this was the
argument for it
so what did happen and this is this is
my only interaction with I guess the
followers of Nick Fuentes was uh you
were there actually organizing with q a
when we were used to do q a we'd say
everyone who has a a sort of a
confrontational question right
adversarial go on this side and then
anyone's a fan this is the line and we
would go one and one yeah one and one so
that no one just dominates the
conversation yeah
and we knew because they sort of had
like a hierarchy with I guess the
gripers yeah who was going to go first
and then follow-up questions and I think
we actually have an overlay here from
Texas A M yeah that was one of the
gentlemen there with uh the cross
because we knew he was he was I was
standing right behind him and the minute
that somebody and I'm not afraid of a
cross obviously as a Christian right of
course but the minute somebody holds it
up like this and it's like going to the
crowd like this I'm like
[Applause]
yeah yeah I was right next to him and
I'm like I'm gonna position myself
between him and you right so what
happened is we said okay line up here
line up there they had their hierarchy
their ranks and then last minute you
said oh you know what actually we're
going to switch the lines that did that
we're gonna switch the lines and now all
of a sudden the leader was put to the
back of the pack and the underling was
put first and just uh uh uh uh and was
stammering and you saw after we
addressed the question everyone else
peel out and we even saw their griper
group afterwards like did you see it
tried to take down the cup like you do
not consider yourself amongst us you
were a stuttering fool you're a coward
ban him from the group so these people
destroy themselves and their only goal
is to destroy they've never done
anything else other than destroy they've
not created anything and right now
they're destroying Kanye West yeah he
was wrong and he's being wrong now yeah
and Kanye West has built himself into
something pretty amazing I can't imagine
being under the microscope that he's
under the stuff that he deals with and I
understand that typing I'm gonna go
Defcon five on the whatever it's just
not something you should ever no right
but you said Defcon Defcon he didn't say
Defcon he said Defcon that was a big
problem didn't I say Defcon you said
Defcon I just genuinely don't think that
he knew it was Defcon oh really I'm
gonna go hey what do you call that
Defcon I'm gonna go Defcon uh Kanye it's
Defcon already wrote it huh oh I thought
he said Twitter ain't gotta edit I I
thought it was me well no he said it
yesterday he said it's something about
American history actually said it yeah
when my head's on the curve and I'm like
it's it's curved
curve but no that happens but uh yeah
with him I just think though that you're
seeing somebody who is seriously his
psyche is broken yeah and I don't like
the idea of anybody being manipulated in
that situation and there's a lot of
people out there who want to hate
another group and this gives a lot of
fodder and a lot of reason for that to
happen and it's a great way for people
to take down Trump too well yeah so
that's the problem though there's so
it's a great resource this is a human
being right who's struggling mentally
and now you're taking him to hate each
other go at somebody it's wrong on every
level in my opinion don't allow yourself
to be galvanized by Kanye West and these
people around him if they're actively
trying to destroy him and or at best at
best
um they couldn't care less about Kanye
West at best at best at worst they're
using him as a pawn to enact the Revenge
that they specified Ad nauseam they were
seeking against Donald Trump in December
of 2020 yes this was not long ago yes
and it has been reiterated many times so
even if you like some of the things that
Kanye has said and I get it
conservatives unfortunately they're real
there's this culture of celebrity
worship because you're looking for some
Transcendent political figure or some
cultural figure to save you and this is
the problem look this is a problem with
our movement and this is a problem with
a lot of a lot of uh back room deals
that take place and a lot of these
conservative entities that exist guess
what there's no bench they can't build
Stars it's not possible and so they go
oh Nicki Minaj oh Kanye West ooh Scott
Baio why because Fox News hasn't created
a star in years they're not able to do
it they don't understand culturally
what's relevant and so they're clinging
to Kanye West and I think putting
blinders on to the exploitation that is
taking place so it really does I'd love
to hear your thoughts uh below I do come
from a place of empathy I think that
he's doing damage and I think he's being
used to do more damage but my heart does
go out to him I do think that he needs
some help and I don't think that he's
probably I don't think he's a hateful
person in his heart of hearts I think
he's not particularly articulate I think
he's an artist he's not a speaker and I
think he's been wrong and he's just sort
of going off like a claymore I agree
with you and I I think he's spreading
any sort of like anti-Semitism rhetoric
I think that's wrong I think that
spreading hates wrong but it's not even
that he's doing that I think that it's
the fact that other people see that he's
kind of getting there yeah then if you
put more words into the ear of somebody
who's broken and go this is where you
target the blame you're training
somebody to speak and to say that's why
he's not very clear in his thoughts when
he's talking right and that's why the
whole thing seems very very shady from
the get-go I mean it it's all very
bizarre and you like you said the whole
dinner does seem like a setup
that's exactly what someone who would
ban me from PayPal would say you take
away my venmo Apple pay
all my payment meth I use cash app oh I
didn't use cash app yet I do direct I do
you're doing wire transfers Bank of
Kanye
now you're just naming payment methods
that's what I do I need to start a bank
what are you some kind of Jew no I just
I'm fine
thank you Kanye we don't have day here
yeah he walked in this is a thing too
like he was really he was wrong for
example with Chase Bank I don't know all
the search but they they basically
de-platform with a bank and is it what's
his name Diamond
but I think he might have actually
walked in like Jamie Diamond who's I
believe head of Chase yeah yeah
something I don't know if he's in New
York his word in New York and I think
Connie just walked into a bank like I
want I want to talk with Jamie Diamond
huh like he's not here that's exactly
what a Jew would say you know he's in
the back get him in the back I want to
talk to him in the back he's not here
he's just on 138th yes Broadway they're
like uh we have two people working he's
talking into the tube and putting in a
little suction get me stuff give me
Jamie
I know you heard me I seen it sure
you're setting an empty tube no open it
put your ear to it please
uh I hope he distances himself I I
really do they're the people you said in
this movement there's a lot of people
that quote unquote are in this movement
I wouldn't associate a lot of people
with what we are trying to do
necessarily with the conservative
movement is or the Republican party is
trying to do that say they are a part of
the movement so I hope he distances
himself from stuff like that yeah I hope
Donald Trump does a better job of
screening next time and making sure he
understands who he's keeping company
with well what ends up happening too is
this ends up sort of coming during the
the the fight that we all have you know
as far as preserving free speech and
Elon Musk and the things that matter
when this isn't necessarily what this is
about this is about people who are maybe
exploiting someone people who are maybe
being dishonest that's not the same
thing as speaking freely and by the way
I think the Kanye should be allowed to
speak freely you should be allowed to of
course dismiss his ideas I completely
agree with that but don't confuse
dismissing or disagreeing with an idea
that has been spoken freely with a lack
of free speech and I think you have some
people on the right who think that if
someone says something controversial and
you say well you know I don't agree with
that you must be working for the The
Establishment to silence them and that's
exactly what these Bad actors are trying
to perpetuate by the way this is
speaking of which we'll get to Elon Musk
and apple that's the big story here of
the day it's a live show Monday through
Thursday at 10 A.M Eastern you can want
nothing would make me happier than
everyone right now on YouTube switching
to rumble right this is the deal you
wanna you wanna have a tectonic shift of
what's Happening online don't be
dependent on the social media ghettos
that are Facebook uh Twitter used to be
we'll see what happens with that but
certainly uh YouTube Instagram right you
have an opportunity right now go over
and watch it on Rumble and certainly on
Mud Club will be playing bad movie lines
you do not have to be dependent on
YouTube but many of you choose to be we
leave the choice to you the people and
don't worry uh until then we'll just pop
that in tomorrow
um I know you're looking for a little
bit uh uh I'm just pissed off that we
installed that balcony okay Gerald do
you have any more thoughts no not that I
can air okay
do it on Monday the Jews got to him huh
what they tell you huh I like Kanye I'll
say that did I get your kid out of
balcony Suge Knight I think he's in
trouble yeah he's in some trouble right
now hilarious if Gerald converted I'm
not black he's just an anti-dentite yes
well today we're all in he doesn't look
Jewish that's odd uh so this is
something we've talked about this in the
past it's there's a little bit of
remedial but it's because I really want
to drive this point home and there are
some new developments we all know okay
Elon Musk Twitter all right
good Elon Musk now his control over
Twitter you look at the list of
billionaires there's one exception here
as far as their I wouldn't even say
political affiliation but uh I guess
their way of viewing the world it's
dogmatic for everyone else and the top
1.1 the top one percent of the one
percent of the one percent of the one
percent I don't know I'm not necessarily
a math guy neither is Kanye no one here
is we really should have one math person
yeah the best of the best
um and Elon Musk is an exception so what
do we have now we have this
Administration this White House
targeting Elon Musk calling to action
all of the other powerful billionaire
Tech oligarchs to silence him and this
comes on the heels of some news
regarding apple and what they are doing
with Elon but here is Jump yeah uh
being asked about Elon Musk and Twitter
and um
it is it is chilling if you understand
what is being said
I'm assuring that Twitter does not
become a factor for misinformation
are you concerned about
the
Elon Musk says there's more and more
subscribers coming online are you
concerned about that and what tools do
you have who is it at the White House
that is really keeping attractive
this is something that we're certainly
keeping an eye on and look
we you know we have always been very
clear
um and that when it comes to social
media platforms it is their
responsibility to make sure that when it
comes to misinformation when we when it
comes to the hate that we're seeing
there's been a close eye on this we all
I hate that monitoring uh what's what's
currently occurring and we see you know
we see it with our own eyes of
monitoring for ourselves what's
happening on Twitter uh but again social
media companies have a responsibility to
prevent their platforms from being used
by any user uh to incite violence she's
on special violence directed at
individuals
there's the switch the president has
been very clear on calling that out
he'll continue to do that and we're
going to continue to monitor the
situation government plays an important
role tell me about section 230 yeah tell
me about the protections afforded to
these companies like the as though they
are a public utility so they are
protected from liability as opposed to a
publisher they want it both ways and she
uses this broad term misinformation who
determines misinformation then hate and
then circles that into uh inciting
violence and I just heard someone on CNN
yesterday use this lazy argument well
you know freedom of speech you're never
actually free to say what you want you
can't yell fire in a crowd of theater
who got this shitty talking point I run
into it all the time you can yell fire
in a crowded theater if there's a fire
it's not the speech that's outlawed as
if you're lying you create a stampede
and there's no fire you are allowed to
yell also there's the idea of private
property if you're in someone's house of
course you have to acquiesce to their
rules if you're in someone's Cineplex
it's the laziest argument that they can
possibly make just like right here they
say oh you know misinformation hate and
therefore equate it with violence
violence is not legal exactly hate is it
might be disgusting it might be
disgusting but it is legal let's pay
attention to this specific portion of
ranch I want to read it again well that
she is reading though really bothers me
yes because that means the whole thing
was set up for her to let you've always
been bothered by leaders wait you think
these questions what are not prepared in
advance I'm not even kidding by the way
they submit their questions oh I know
they're prepared in advance but it's
just he makes it so obvious like when I
host
[Applause]
[Laughter]
look I I could still answer better than
that yes you absolutely I'd be like I
don't know this stuff yeah I don't know
what's your problem yeah what's your
problem what are you a ghost you're
gonna rattle the cupboards can we show
that lady again asking the question just
to bring it up we don't need to
necessarily here but a screen grab Hey
where's Wayne look she's pretty yeah
that lady's about to Rattle the bed
frame
she's 100. I'm surprised jump here I
didn't go full David Blaine like oh [ __ ]
oh
[Laughter]
was wearing glasses just pulls out a
card deck pick a card
yeah she does a coin trick
it's all over all right uh it's not
being pulled out of an ear so here uh
this is the a quote from kjp that's what
they mean uh you know we have always
been very clear and that when it comes
to social media platforms it is their
responsibility to make sure that when it
comes to misinformation when we when it
comes to the hate that we're seeing that
they take action that they continue to
take action okay I'd love to see your
comments below uh question
yeah who decides what is misinformation
yeah who decides what is hate for a
while it was a CDC it was a who which is
which is ironic because the who
determined
what would be classified as
misinformation while they were actively
hating Taiwan by denying its existence
well the who said that the CDC was
spreading misinformation at one point
because they disagreed and by the way
they were both probably right yes can we
by the way can we just sit for a minute
in all of that sentence her quote
which one that was written down for her
that was it was written down and she
screwed it up that bad when we come to
it comes and we and I think he and we
will continue to it it's just like can
we get somebody your job is to speak why
you got to be racist I'm not racist
yes please you're the spokes okay so
it's not so much that she's a female or
that she's black it's that she's an
idiot nailed it good okay I think we're
on the same page you judge people on the
individual qualities right and I
particularly have a disdain for idiots
jeez black and yellow red and white
they're all morons in our site right
okay
October report by The Intercept we also
know that the DHS the FBI are actively
colluding with big Tech remember a long
time ago was jensaki saying we hope that
Spotify and then insert you know how
they wanted to censor Rogan here we now
know beyond any shadow of a doubt that
they're including with big Tech this is
the thing at one point in time the
government uh determined winners and
losers and it was the enforcing arm was
Big Business sort of in the industrial
revolution that's where power was
Consolidated as we sort of transformed
from a largely agriculturally based
society we now have a flip where really
it is a few businesses that control 90
of your life and the enforcing arm is
the government they are doing the
bidding for these big Tech platforms
those are the organizations that wield
more power than any government on Earth
and our government is in their pocket
hit the like button if you have a
problem with this because while we're
talking about this right now the
algorithms want to tell you that we are
dead on Youtube
here's something else I don't know if
you remember this
um uh according to that report actually
I think yeah we have an overlay uh the
Microsoft executive Matt Masterson
texted
Jen easterly the DHS director platforms
have got to get comfortable with
government it's really interesting how
hesitant they remain hey hold on a
second I actually this is a fundamental
worldview difference yeah yeah I believe
what are supposed to be open platforms
should be as uncomfortable as humanly
[ __ ] possible with government
to begin with those are just the ABCs of
me
why would we start from the point of
they should be comfortable what good has
come with starting off comfortable and
trusting of government well that's
that's not the shot really not this
country yeah exactly the shock that
these guys have that I can't I can't
believe they won't just trust us it's
like have you read any of the news like
do you see anything in the last just
last year why we wouldn't trust the
government to do what's right in every
situation right we're going to get to a
little bit more of it with the railroads
and pushing that beyond the election
there is nobody who's gotten a shot
that's deeply concerned right now none
no no I haven't talked to them
personally where they're like uh oh
are we back to MLK Malcolm X yes I don't
know which one I'm more like yes I don't
know I'm like Gandhi yes if Gandhi was
thick almost yeah
[Laughter]
no hunger strike for me that was a pitch
move did a lot of good I feel good set
himself on fire in Tiananmen Square
I don't know why I just do yeah well you
know what look we're all on fire for
something we're flammable I just feel
like going to hell yeah oh geez I feel
like I'm in hell right now me too so uh
here's the thing the the the
administration right now and by the way
they're cronies uh of course in big Tech
they are terrified as it relates to Elon
Musk of one person they cannot control
they have been so in control of the
narrative for so long uh with I mean
completely unfettered that the the mere
notion of Elon Musk allowing people from
both the left and the right we're not
talking about Elon Musk removing people
from the left in other words you have
all these other platforms that the left
is allowed and people on the right are
throttled or they are banned we've
experienced this directly you can go
back and and watch I don't know pick a
week any week whether we're banned from
Facebook that week used to be Twitter
certainly YouTube right we know this all
Elon Musk is saying is allow both sides
to have a seat at the table so what
happens you just heard that from the
White House you just heard that from uh
I thought Jean-Pierre was on CNN out of
the corner of my eye but it's not it's
just a guy a soccer players it's just
the corner of my eye it's not that
everyone with the hair looks it's just
that I saw that I said oh the little
jumpier speaking right now no it turns
out it's a oh okay soccer player okay so
so yes yes the straight soccer player
wow the White House can't control Elon
themselves they're not powerful enough
but other companies are that's the dog
whistle so Elon Musk tweeted this out I
have no reason to not believe him Apple
apparently is considering removing
Twitter from the App Store
that's also important to note he also by
the way uh musk retweeted a post by the
blockchain publisher library that
claimed Apple censored its material uh
something else let's be really clear
about this we don't know if this is
entirely true we're hearing this from
Elon Musk we do know that Apple has
pulled advertising from Twitter that
part can be confirmed uh I don't know if
they're threatening to pull in from the
Apple Store I haven't heard anything
from Tim Cook yet but you have to go
with the information that is available
let's go to the tail of the tape Apple
their history in 2021 Apple along with
Google completely banned parlor from its
App Store yeah just to be clear do you
remember when parlor was the next big
thing all Apple has to do is make that
threat earlier on with Uber they did the
same thing now Uber was doing some stuff
that they shouldn't have been doing but
they threatened to remove them from the
Apple Store that will get CEOs fired
that will get boards motivated to change
in the company or it will get people's
companies to crumble to the ground
because they depend on the App Store to
be in the public and we'll get to the
numbers the numbers are shocking you
need the advertisers you need the
advertisers and you need to be available
on the App Store absolutely and you
don't just give somebody a U2 album
right well it's not so much give as
thrusted upon that's what I mean they
forced it on us is for them to take
Twitter away it makes no sense do you
have any idea how embarrassing that was
I open up my phone and it's bombing and
I say hey what are you doing it's just
it's just gay porn yeah
it's something that's not the edge is it
no it's a snuff film Apple still hasn't
answered for that yet no no they still
have an answer and now you're out there
making threats yeah come on now you
still owe us one that's just like a that
is the modern equivalent to a dirty bomb
it is that's how you destroy
civilizations from within I I would have
rather than sex stuff yep well you did
it anyway but there are two are
unrelated yeah that's true so 2021 they
banned parlor from the App Store okay
then you also have to take into account
that hey all right they banned them up
because of hate speech right they're
against they're against hate they're
against extremists well okay that would
hold water if Apple didn't also do the
bidding of communist dictatorships of
authoritarian regimes here you have
recently in October 2022 Apple disabled
the automatic airdrop function on
iPhones in China it's an automatic right
now if you haven't if you have an iPhone
go you can airdrop yeah it's built in
they had to proactively disable it in
order
to align themselves with the Communist
Chinese government yes Apple hates the
Chinese people and love is a CCP right
and some people right now are posting
that as though that happened in relation
to these protests no it was a guy
holding a sign up basically calling for
the removal of the president Xi Jinping
and they did that just for that one
thing not the protests that are going on
right now it's even worse right right
the way the protesters and I asked this
question yesterday I should have an
overlay of that guy yeah the banner
overlay B6 the removal of yeah right
there I was wondering how these guys
were communicating because China has
such strict control over media and how
people are asking that yeah yesterday
they were airdropping stuff to each
other that's how some of this
information was getting out plus we know
that there's not anymore tech savvy that
can get around some of these rules but
now you have no ability to do that apple
is basically saying yeah I know this is
going on but now you don't have to it's
right it's you don't have the ability to
keep no no no no no parlor is a much
greater threat than XI yes yes how many
uyghurs have the CEOs of parlor killed
oh gosh well they're getting around to
it say upwards of zero yeah no you know
it's a rounding error yeah that's true
right so I'm just glad that they that
they stand by what they believe yes
exactly as Elon Musk you know that's
that's the evil right there the guy who
moved his uh facilities to Texas also we
have in August 2021 Apple banned the
anti-government Engravings in China Hong
Kong Taiwan again are you noticing the
pattern here when they always line up on
the side of tyranny why because they can
continue to keep a good portion of the
population subjugated they benefit
the people of China don't hey Apple
benefits hey uh meta Google they benefit
you don't when you don't have access to
information when you don't have access
to opinions when you don't have access
to educational resources they benefit at
your expense and that's when you realize
that this is no longer a government for
the People by the people because they
seek to benefit companies like apple and
not just Apple let's just get into the
larger problem here and this is really
this is why when people say who do you
think is going to be the the Republican
candidate not that I don't care it's not
nearly as relevant though
as this consolidation of Power with
really five companies if you wanna if
you want to be very generous 10.
so let's look at just a handful of
companies that control the entire flow
of information outside of a recently
Elon Musk right so you've got Jeff Bezos
at Amazon you've got uh Sundar pichai I
think it's how it's pronounced and Susan
majeski that's Google and YouTube you
have uh number three you have Zuckerberg
Facebook and meta then you have Tim Cook
at what am I at number four now Tim Cook
at Apple and then you have Bill Gates
Microsoft that's five people that's five
people let me ask you especially if the
something like parlor is removed from
the App Store God forbid they try and do
something like that with with a place
like Rumble okay if those people decide
in unison and in tandem they say hey you
know what we don't like this opinion
we're going to get rid of this person
like I don't know they did with Donald
Trump Alex Jones that was a sitting
president Donald Trump if they decide
that where are you going to get the
information it's not even just a
monopoly it's that these people all work
together and right now you are seeing
them work together in real time to try
and eliminate their one competitor Elon
Musk that is ball retractingly scary and
if you don't believe me here's Steve
Jobs wife who by the way very fetching
he did well for himself despite being a
dick Lauren Powell jobs talking about
the cultural narrative it was pretty
obvious to me that we could build we you
know we we build out in a very
cross-disciplinary way our work you know
Capital investing and policy and
philanthropy and we could do this work
forever and ever and we could have the
narrative
children's podcast
about someone who's my husband has a lot
of power who's completely contrary to us
and we could never get to the place
where we think we're part of she's
probably important medical society and
so it was obvious that if we could be
part of the
the creation of cultural narrative that
would that would enhance and amplify all
the work that we're doing which is
Hillary Clinton talked about today is
telling the story getting the content
out there yeah she was yes yeah yeah so
these are notice that Kamala Harris is
contributing nothing like every
conversation
do you ever see you buying something
bigger like the New York Times for
example is it for sale it could be for
you oh good for is it for sale by the
way she's a stakeholder Apple Disney the
Atlantic just to be clear hey hold on a
second if you can create narratives I
thought your job was to build phones and
like computers that are somewhat
see-through that kind of look like a
messenger bag remember those were fun
yeah yeah but no they said create
narratives by getting the story out no
no you want a story out that's it and
suppress not stories you don't like
right exactly not everybody's story not
the truth not what's actually going on
in places like China you want your story
out so that it doesn't mess with your
friends Steve Jobs definitely didn't
create the good father app no no he did
not he would never let that in the store
no he was also by the way he was a
stand-in for the good son really wow
tiny hands so here's the thing um Apple
and Google by the way you need to let go
of they control 95 of the app markets 95
you just heard from her point of view
how important it is to create these
cultural shifts to control the narrative
she has a steak in apple Disney the
Atlantic 95 of the app store or app
market sorry is Apple and Google when we
get to social media big Tech 71 percent
of people access their social their news
sorry from social media wow and by the
way I'm pretty sure that is a low ball
that's probably a lowball number but
this isn't like being able to play a
game on your phone that's not what we're
talking about access to information is
controlled by two companies right now
that's it I'm at five well Google and
these guys on the App Store yeah 71 get
it from it that's massive no no 71 get
from social media right 95 controlled by
the app market is controlled by two
companies that's what I'm saying by two
companies who by the way we know beyond
any shadow of a doubt are complicit with
this corrupt government it's not a
conspiracy theory yeah all of the
references are available at
latoscredit.com again like I said we
really do try and seek truth and we try
and make it so that you can see truth go
and check out the references go and read
these reports they're very long they're
a dry read that's why we put them in
this format in the show because I know
that many of you can't be bothered
because I hate having to read them
that's good for you though these
companies while we also talk about this
the great wealth transfer you know
Bernie Sanders uh who by the way gets
the support of a lot of these people in
big Tech they want you to they want you
to hate each other the top one percent
well guess what a lot of business owners
small business owners they're in that
top one percent right when you're
talking about this top marginal tax rate
joint household income 400 000 according
to this Administration which just so
happens to be the exact salary of the
White House on the flip side let's talk
about the wealth transfer from the
middle class because some old school
conservatives in the baby boom
generation maybe aren't aware of what
has been happening right now it is true
there has been a robbing of the middle
class and upper middle class and I would
even say upper upper middle class
everyone from the lower middle class to
making low to mid six figures that money
is being transferred to five people five
billionaires the top five billionaires
during the pandemic saw their wealth
grow by a total of 101 billion dollars
that's 26 yes 26 increase in their Bezos
and Zuckerberg alone their combined
wealth increased 76 billion dollars and
by the way these five companies I just
mentioned to you together guess how much
they're worth
a trillion 6.3 trillion dollars wow
seriously wow you are not being
subjugated by your government your
government is enforcing the whims of
these companies yeah and here's
something else that's pretty important
you saw Washington Post praising Apple
for maybe removing Elon musk's Twitter
that's how they try and label it now
from the App Store you saw a bunch of
media Outlets praising this you saw Don
Lemon on the failing Morning Show
talking about how this was a good thing
well here's here's another wrinkle
six Corp who advertises when they say Oh
look The advertisers are pulling off
Twitter okay
I would like to advertise on Twitter
this happened remember with Google and
YouTube they wouldn't let us advertise
anything and they wouldn't let
advertisers advertise on their show and
I'm like wait hold on a second I'm on
both sides I would like to have these
people advertise on my show I know there
are a lot of advertisers who would like
to advertise on my show you won't let
them and you won't let me advertise on
their programming what is going on like
ah we can't tell you that and I asked
why they said because you're a stranger
of
so who runs the advertising they're
polling well six companies six
corporations control 90 percent of media
Outlets what do you have you have
Comcast NBC Universal you have Viacom
you have uh CBS which is CBS Paramount
uh gosh I'm trying to remember you have
uh ABC Disney
then you have 18 T and you have news
course so six corporations
NBC Universal ABC Disney CBS Viacom a t
news core
and hey we all know that these people
de-platform one person so what you get
to say is look advertisers are pulling
off of these platforms because it's six
companies who decide to work with you
because then you give them favorable
advertising uh splits you give them you
just you favor them as it relates to
advertising period we've seen this on
YouTube for example remember Vox with
the Vox apocalypse what no one really
told you is that Vox was working with
NBC and Vox was producing a show
co-producing a show with YouTube who
then decided that we were going to be
demonetized because Vox wanted that
wanted us to be demonetized they control
the advertising dollars they control the
App Store and this Administration has
made it clear that they are going to
wield that power they are going to do
their bidding do you feel free you
really think that you would take the
power of Washington DC over the power of
Silicon Valley or Hollywood and maybe if
that's the case you need a CAT scan
you need a CAT scan and do you know how
you know it's not true how much time do
you spend arguing about Donald Trump and
DeSantis right how much but what lights
the news on fire
Kanye West yeah
you guys all understand that culture is
more important than politics but you
spend so much time in something that
bears little significance as it relates
to the fundamental changing a new
weaving of the tapestry of our society
five big tech companies six media
entities yeah one Administration dog
whistling yeah so one of the things Elon
Musk said about Twitter is that you have
to disconnect it from being dependent on
advertisers because of this very problem
right right because it will make you
censor your content in a way maybe that
you shouldn't and he is a big Free
Speech Advocate I know he's not perfect
in that regard there's some stuff we
need to kind of still work on but he's
pushing for free speech he said if it
dies in America that's the beginning of
the end like he understands the problem
right and he's trying to get free from
these people because think about it this
way if you don't say and do the right
things as a company
these guys are going to sick the liberal
rage mob on you and these advertisers
are going to start you know feeling the
the or sorry not the advertisers the
companies that are advertising you're
going to start feeling it in their
bottom line and investors get pissed off
and people lose their jobs that's
exactly what's going on here yeah you
and I talked about this stuff that
Trends isn't stuff that is trending no
it's stuff that they want to Trend a lot
of times you see something with 25 000
tweets trending and something with 200
000 tweets not trending right so you're
being pushed automation into your face
these companies have so much control and
by coupling with the advertisers they
can make or break your company and they
have to do is remove you look at
ourselves and then tripling with the
government but if you can't even sell a
shirt that doesn't say a bad word yeah I
know that's right yeah we got removed
from Shopify we had the PayPal every
single company we've been dealing with
this for a very very long time you can
go back to 2009 with me with a blue bed
sheet yeah Dave sorry no no I was just
saying it just seems to create a
subserving class of Voters I mean really
people who think they're voting at this
point yeah I mean there's no I can't I
just try to find the logic in it yeah
it's not there well it's because it's
ideologically driven because it's power
it's power and all it is is power and
that's if it that fact is crazy I've
heard that before but somehow I forgot
it that six corporations control all the
information that's published but the
scarier part is they're all of the same
agenda yes and that's the thing that is
is most terrifying and they want you to
believe that all of America by the way
you're talking about well over three
million votes Republicans won the most
recent let's say this at the worst case
scenario it's a split
it's not 90 10 but the people who decide
what you see are 90 10. let me ask you
this because I've lived this and it's 50
50 with all that stuff being kicked out
of the App Store with parlor with
everything being taken down that's
pretty amazing considering a lot of
people must still have some morals
imagine if they allowed equal time oh
crazy hey what happened to the fairness
uh the fairness Doctrine remember that
that was only to do with AM radio
because they didn't like that Rush was
doing so well they didn't like that they
only had ABC NBC CBS CNN and they said
oh it's like in Russia has too big of an
audience we need the government to
guarantee equal time now when it relates
to the internet hey where are you guys
where are you guys and asking for
fairness and by the way I don't think
the government should determine what is
fair because we see what they're doing
now they are determining what is hate
let's use logic here for a second
when they say look all the advertisers
are pulling okay do you understand for
example that the advertisers let's say
on Don lemon's podcast I believe
everyone has a podcast I'm sure he does
what
what are the reason that his advertisers
would be diametrically opposed to the
worldview of the advertisers on this
show meaning Walther good ranchers
they're very likely clear they're very
likely not advertising on Don lemon's
show why because you have half the
country less than half and then you have
this half of the country so if a portion
of advertisers are pulling because they
don't like that there are I wouldn't
even say conservatives but they don't
like that the platform is open and more
free
how is there not another class of
advertisers who would want to step in
this is the conversation that we had
with YouTube Right Where I said hey look
you guys say that no advertisers want to
be associated with my channel which is
basic [ __ ] pumpkin spice conservatism
let's be honest uh what about uh firearm
companies what about hunting companies
Bass Pro what what about uh what about
uh coffee companies that aren't lined up
with Starbucks what what we've had to go
after our own sponsors and by the way
many of these sponsors are not allowed
to advertise on YouTube and if they are
they're not allowed to advertise on the
kinds of programming that they want to
advertise on and then YouTube releases a
public announcement saying advertisers
are pulling on conservative that's what
happens with Twitter yeah they borrow
these advertisers or they have a meeting
behind the scenes saying hey don't you
advertise on Twitter don't you support
this Elon Musk this Elon Musk competitor
right now or we'll go you might lose you
might lose some of your your tax exempt
statuses or protections and they say
okay we're not going and then they go
out and say look look the mainstream
view is that Twitter needs to censor
more just look at the advertisers it
does doesn't pass the sniff test
it doesn't and unfortunately
conservatives have failed you in a
multitude of ways because while the left
is looking at critical mass and let me
leave you with this because there is a
real silver lining here the left is
trying to achieve critical mass Facebook
I don't know how many billions of users
requires critical mass to work so what
do they do they lose money for a very
long time so did Amazon saying we need
to get to the point where we control a
population Facebook that's what they did
Amazon that's what they did YouTube I
don't know if they're making money yet
but that's what they've done they've
said okay you know what we need to build
critical mass
of viewers so that then we can determine
how information flows unfortunately
people on the right and I can tell you
this are obsessed with monetizing their
base
look at for example look at parlor how
quickly were you sent out promotional
emails was that list rented out
this happens with a lot of people on the
right they're going no no hold on let's
make money right now we need to be a
business first we need to well okay you
can make some money that's why we create
free content
and we have mug Club where you can go
and support us so that we're able to do
both we're able to give something to you
so you get your money's worth but we do
not remove ourselves from these
platforms and concede that territory
that's why I'm excited about a place
like Rumble Rumble is an open platform
and they also have a I think they have
their their like pay service thing
that's similar to like a mug Club thing
yeah but Rumble is saying hey look we
are just going to be what a lot of
people claim that they want on YouTube
we are not going to censor you unless
you are doing something against the law
and on Election night in the midterms
after we were suspended no one even came
close we are at a point right now an
inflection point where if the people on
the right the powers that be the people
with all the money the billionaires on
the right if they see the inflection
point right now oh wait a second
we have enough people we can hit
critical mass we don't have to fight
billions of users hundreds of millions
of users with trying to monetize a few
hundred thousand by renting out just a
mailing list they need to perk up though
they need to have ears to hear and eyes
to see and here's the thing maybe some
people in positions of power will not be
doing that on the right and it's
unfortunate
we will yeah
we always will and I am happy to go out
on that shield and you know what I know
that a lot of you out there are willing
to do it with us and I'm glad that
someone like Elon Musk for all of his
potential flaws is willing to do that as
well this is an inflection point
Elon Musk Twitter
and Records being shattered on Rumble
that are bigger than you that's the
first night there were bigger numbers on
Rumble than on YouTube that hasn't
happened ever
but we've got to shift our Focus here we
can't continually concede the cultural
battles and say who's going to win the
primary I don't give a [ __ ] three point
something billion people are in a
communist app
pay attention to that I don't know is it
me let's you know what YouTube thank you
remember we don't have time to do the
rail update it's a bunch of okay here
look spoiler alert this was going to
happen before the election you're
talking about the railway workers and
Biden just like you said with OPEC and
releasing the barrels he said hey
Railway workers can you just hold it off
until after the election so that I can
win they said okay and now sure enough
they're striking because I want more
free [ __ ] there you go you can check the
references at lottery.com that doesn't
be much more to the story than that
YouTube I'm angry enough right now we're
gonna go play Bad movie lines which we
cannot play here piss off immediately
foreign